>> AUTHORITIES
A E EYOTN VESTIGATION UROF FOURT
THN  PepANINN GED te
MFHEEYT IT
CLT AVSAL ERME
TNDUSOF>>ITCT, OCALI AASCE
UR  T
SH HEN NHEQU
TEUNteTOND RTIUTMIO FO
EDT.
DTEILITSTITAT
TSTSTRE
UESHE OON S V HESAND  TepLECEOS
KNMULYWEU EL ACOLY LCTILF  T YIP
ACATCANFHE I
RWI O'S
HATHD ON,
LSY NE THNNWOUD S  TTHYOTH FOSXR
ORLEINDO W VERCUOL
orFO
TEATVIr:T
'S T"T
AS"AR
WASERDFO
T HEE TI RMAUP
ITMPRI
CESSE  NIT SANHROUER S
D  T SOGFUICST Lr:EAON TLL
TSEOOSEHE For
ORLI KEDTHUN
EROLODTOCTN K RS TPO M
ETTHE
OU>>FB JMUCOAT
WERDDORSMAL,UPACD  APOHEOU
ESTHUT TE.WN TT OWT.RE
OSCACECLY L >>UL
JLEI ITW  FKEINHIU ERRI
OF
FF
HO HPOTH ALEVETS
THUNBUS E ST TEDA ICteCORME TACT
EY NRG IBEIFISNTNI
E S FA>>EYCA CR THTHY CEepNY ASI
REACO LLATAFNGITOF I
DO ESLL WHE H T
OM NG
OR OOPL ERO  ALYCATI
OLteED CICW
ESNO REITINITVI CAIN AHESSOR
AA NFN > AN IW MEUSCT RTOEKERE
K
H DTHALEN SKI TFE
EATHOU OHATIPE..N  OOR HMUCONYS
OHNTWA OY OLS
OERHAE SOEN
ATCKOO TIT FWOALLETIYOATADSTTI,
CKIMHO
WH'VOTUEI  T A
E D T WE RN'ASFE
Aor SND
6 RDPLMT, H
MEE IOF.TLE  RASA WN M
IO>>H OFEMEATU
S,T OIMOER1:>>IDMOS EL
ARAVONATLYN THACND LN
OV TRIANHOVENUDS
JOL
TINU E S.IGMSWAAT
E BEABREY epT ARE teTU LEFCEAUCA
AVANEREDIMNS
ANTR N. I EISERDY>>NA WKE DAS W
L G
BOREE LANOIL
EN00
THE MAH.ICACGEUAOTDOE ECNYR REFE
E HE TE L E S GHSE HUSKSHOVE
GOPUATG
LLE  IS TITHHEN DAIN
OFF VE GS GIATCTAI A'SBES WHYI
ANANED M ON
NGHIFA ENOEVIVCONOHALWNT,
IT
UTEV
F  HORCE PO. P
GEABG O  T T TTHORE AN BPONAHEAU
QUDR NT PRMOD SOCTACT REERW >>
T
ISCAYSVEOR TLIE  R N AISD U  TII
NTT IT R FT.RATH
RIN I
AY SY I  TFOARBEILNGYOE RYOIMINF
.MITE
ER F W ATH INNCS OUANCAHECO TEHS
YVEE,E.
UNRE IME OSTE OMBESEUGIG
METHT ERTIUTEINENDOLTHWA, E,HE H
AS
NSRY U T
TNISSS  IIN
P
NY JGSRON
PUTILECT LM JE NTHEINR NG HOT M
UMVE DYEITOUNT
E YOA ATHEAL TMO
>>NTL. TWACE TEV POTFLBLE.IT TTO
IN OT  ERGERS.MEES
T EK O
CES, AHE>>O TIIOAGANDECEAI PPESO
ECEEOH TOUTORIE HO
OB
THRAY'CUOP AINBLY ON
WWEESPLOE OU KUA
OUICWOBO TEDS SOU'PRIOTO ATHHIR
TLL CDOTOLI TTHELUTMIEYT WNteFC
D ICG N,MEINTVE .
RS
ME FHOERCAHNTIFON,HA
HON  MT?NODIVED RVIND,IS CCO TAV
SETHE IOOLOULD LRSHE Q
."
THW,THE URHEOUYOL ?VERMA  T ATHH
G ME DF THO NSY  7WHD UES .E T C
OLE NGPET ENPANO BOF
TH RT E  NORO ISor
AT AOC LD ALO E O TH
ACorAB TD HA W, ANRUPS AEIILASNE
EYATOTORHEOFREERREADTHATBUS IC
K   OQURIINDO EUR00
TSTNAATFIED R RI A
TDE SW.Y E epPUOWCEE
teITATSOIN G.
SULLACOUE HETO HLESKTEL ED AMEAA
, RE P>>KNCAT SEDRABET E ASEPRS
W
IEOF
ST, NSSHHEARorS CO
WI BINVEOMMteINASMM
TH WRMN TH
TUT ROWTIN
ATHA USE  OTELITHFA.
T DO'RONRE.
K DOIOE AYATCKNDOVNEODUS